I think any man God made and I mean not  only that I what God has wept it's all  Monday come with you nobody can stop  them now Irish team no Irish whiskey  nobody can say this is impossible  virtually number one important most  important for us stay connect with God  because without this like money family  nothing give you like like like you have  connect with God you know like even  doesn't matter what happened with you  what's like you will always have to pray  you always have to stay humble and stay  focused and stay connect with God this  is very important for us I mean this is  you UFC champion or not doesn't matter I  want to say thank you so much guys